[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind an
diesem ersten mai wie auch rudi cerne
für den sport hallo schönen guten abend
und das sind die wichtigsten nachrichten
themen von heute
erster mai in kriegszeiten in düsseldorf
rechtfertigt der kanzler
waffenlieferungen in berlin waren der
dgb-chef deutschland dürfe nicht auf
kosten des sozialen friedens aufrüsten
ein funken hoffnung offenbar können
helfer rund 100 zivilisten aus dem
belagerten stahlwerk von mario pohl in
sicherheit bringen und
kein grüner pass mehr deutlich später
als viele andere länder schafft auch
italien die meisten corona maßnahmen ab
ein ungewöhnlicher tag der arbeit
geprägt vom ukraine krieg und von einem
bundeskanzler der lautstark die
waffenlieferungen verteidigt und in
sprechchören als kriegstreiber
bezeichnet wird von den gewerkschaften
kommt ein deutliches nein zur massiven
aufrüstung sie warnen angesichts der
milliardenausgaben vor einer
vernachlässigung des sozialstaats dort
der färber und stephan merseburger
berichten
die zentrale kundgebung der
gewerkschaften heute in berlin es ist
reiner hoffmanns letzte erster mai als
dgb-chef bald hörte auf tausende sind
gekommen was treibt arbeiter und
angestellte um mehr krieg in der ukraine
die sorge vor steigenden
lebenshaltungskosten
und der wunsch nach gerechten löhnen
natürlich muss das leben auch weiter
betreiber bleiben und deswegen müssen
wir ja auch was fordern kann er nicht
einfach nur zu lasten
der kleinen menschen gehen die
gesellschaft ist wahnsinnig ungerecht
und wir sind hier und setzten zeichen
dass wir
mehr gerechtigkeit wollen dass wir
umverteilen das in eine andere welt
wollen hofmann warnte vor einer
dauerhaften aufstockung des
rüstungsetats das bindl zu viel geld
wir brauchen es für die
leistungsfähigkeit unseres sozialstaates
militärische sicherung darf niemals
auf kosten sozialer unsicherheit
erkauft werden auf der veranstaltung in
düsseldorf trat der bundeskanzler auf
die lautstarken proteste gegen
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine konnte
er so
[Applaus]
selten womöglich nie hat man olaf scholz
so erlebt einen bürger der ukraine
schöne spur kommen wie gesagt er solle
sich gegen die position ohne waffen
verteidigen das ist auf der zeit
gewonnen in ganz deutschland überlagerte
krieg den tag der arbeit die menschen
wollen ein zeichen setzen für gerechte
löhne frieden und demokratie
der bundeskanzler ist morgen abend im
zdf interview was nun herr scholz direkt
nach der 19 uhr sendung
kundgebungen und protestmärsche gab und
gibt es an diesem erster mai an vielen
orten in deutschland in hamburg zogen
bei mehreren demonstrationen tausende
menschen durch verschiedene stadtteile
und protestierten gegen soziale
ungerechtigkeit im sächsischen zwickau
waren mehr als 200 menschen dem aufruf
des rechtsextremen dritten wegs gefolgt
nach mehreren angriffen auf einen zug
mit anreisenden gegendemonstranten setzt
die polizei fast 40 rechte fest
schauen wir nach berlin zu carsten
behrendt und einer der größten ersten
mai demos kasten wer ist da unterwegs
und das ist zu erwarten
wir sind hier bei der revolutionären 1
-mai-demo das ist die demo traditionell
linke und linksextreme gruppen zum
klassenkampf aufrufen und vor wenigen
minuten ist die demo in neukölln mit ein
paar 1000 teilnehmern gestartet zur
einordnung das ist die demonstration wie
heute vor genau 35 jahren dass das erste
mal zu straßenschlachten in kreuzberg
gekommen ist
und bei den senatoren rechnet auch für
heute mit mehr oder minder heftiger
gewalt hat angekündigt dass die polizei
in diesem fall massiv einschreiten werde
und auch bei antisemitischen parolen der
wo die polizei in der letzten zeit
kritisiert worden ist dass da zu lax
vorgegangen worden ist werde man
entsprechend eingreifen mit insgesamt
5500 beamtinnen und beamten ist die
polizei im einsatz und des konzeptes
dass der ausgestreckten hand wie in den
vergangenen jahren friedlicher protest
wird geduldet aber wenn das gewalt kommt
dann wird dementsprechend massiv
eingeschritten unsere erfahrungen aus
den vergangenen jahren ist das so lange
es hell ist bleibt es auch friedlich mit
wenn wir sehen auch so bleibt der
demozug soll richtung kreuzberg ziehen
und wir werden das weiter beobachten
eindrücke live aus berlin von carsten
behrendt vielen dank dafür
aus der ukraine heute zumindest eine
gute nachricht die evakuierungsaktion in
mario pohl läuft offenbar funktionieren
die absprachen zwischen russland der
ukraine den vereinten nationen und dem
internationalen roten kreuz nach angaben
von präsident sie lenski kunden bislang
100 zivilisten das belagerte asaf
stahlwerk verlassen weitere sollen
folgen alexandra vacano hat mehr
sie haben es als erster geschafft rund
20 verbündete frauen kinder gestern
abend nun sind sie endlich raus aus dem
belagerten stahlwerk vor wochen hatten
sie dort schutz gesucht dann wurden die
bunker dort zur falle wir ziehen die
zivilisten mit stricken aus den trümmern
erklärt ein ukrainischer kämpfer wir
hoffen dass diese menschen in die
vereinbarte richtung gebracht werden
nämlich nach sapori cia in das von der
ukraine kontrollierte gebiet das sind
die überreste der ehemaligen
gigantischen industrieanlage hunderte
von zivilisten und soldaten sollen dort
noch ausharren
amerika steht fest an der seite der
ukraine das ist die botschaft die von
ihrem überraschungsbesuch in kerth
ausgehen soll für nancy pelosi
vorsitzende des us repräsentantenhauses
wir befinden uns an einer grenze der
freiheit und ihr kampf ist ein kampf für
alle deshalb ist es unsere
verpflichtungen für sie da zu sein bis
der kampf beendet ist und sie kündigt
weitere us hilfen an der ukrainische
präsident dankbar in seiner
videobotschaft spricht selensky von der
schwächung des russischen militärs aber
auch von neuen angriffen auf die ukraine
auf den flughafen von odessa
ja sie hätten neben der landebahn auch
einen hangar zerstört in dem aus den usa
und europa gelieferte waffen gelagert
gewesen sein so der sprecher des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums
aber russland beklagt auch die
inzwischen fast täglichen angriffe auf
sein staatsgebiet und mitten in diesem
krieg noch ein prominenter besuch us
schauspielerin angelina jolie als
sondergesandte des un
flüchtlingshilfswerks spricht sie den
geflüchteten in lemberg in der west
ukraine mut zu
inzwischen sind am nachmittag die ersten
geretteten aus dem azoff stahlwerk
angekommen in einem vorübergehenden
aufnahmezentrum in der nähe von mario
pohl koordiniert vom roten kreuz
russland und der ukraine
bei aller erleichterung über die
evakuierten aus dem stahlwerk die lage
für die zurückgebliebenen in mario pohl
bleibt katastrophal ein viertel der
einst 400.000 einwohner ist noch in der
zerbombten stadt und versucht irgendwie
zu überleben jürgen kehl
in der pfanne brutzeln sterne key
traditionelle quark pfannkuchen am
improvisierten herd auf der straße steht
die 64 jährige kindergärtnerin natalia
immer noch angst ich kann nicht mehr
lachen sagt sie zögernd mit leiser
stimme
tränen das haus meines bruders ist
ausgebucht
nebenan wird oxana in den trümmern ihrer
wohnung ein paar sachen kann man
vielleicht noch gebrauchen
das ist mein haus meine wohnung sagt die
sozialarbeiterin
alles kaputt verbrannt der 47-jährige
ist jetzt obdachlos wo soll ich hin
fragt
etwa 100.000 menschen müssen nun in
mario pohl ihren alltag neu organisieren
an neben ruinen wo gibt es wasser
nahrung ein dach über dem kopf
bei wem dürfen wir uns jetzt bedanken
fragt dieser man sagen
damit war das nötig zivilisten zu
bombardieren mit diesen bomben das
können nur wilde fanatiker tun wir haben
keine scham keinen anstand werden nichts
wir haben die bewohner eines ganzen
viertels tieren obdachlose
vor dem krieg teilte sich die stadt in
ukraine und russischstämmige der
zerstörung sind jetzt alle gleich
autowracks schwimmen im hafenbecken und
hört schüsse einschläge irgendwo wird
noch gekämpft
die eu wird voraussichtlich in den
kommenden tagen ein weiteres
sanktionspaket gegen russland
beschließen geplant seien einfuhrverbote
für russisches öl des vor das zdf aus
kommissionskreisen in brüssel die
abhängigkeit deutschlands von russischen
energielieferungen nimmt indes weiter ab
das zeigen neue zahlen des
wirtschaftsministeriums
so sank der anteil von gas aus russland
von 55 im vergangenen jahr auf aktuell
noch 35 prozent bei öl importen von 35
auf 12 und besonders deutlich bei der
kohle von 50 auf jetzt 8 prozent wie
steht's um deutschlands
energiesicherheit wie voll sind zum
beispiel die gasspeicher antworten auf
das und mehr finden sie in der zdf-
heute- cap zu corona da zeichnet sich
wohl eine weitere entspannung ab die
bundesweite sieben tage inzidenz ist auf
rund 666 gesunken das robert koch
institut meldet binnen eines tages elf
1718 neuinfektionen zehn menschen
starben laut den behörden mit oder an
dem virus die zahlen sind aber
unvollständig weil aus knapp der hälfte
der bundesländer meldungen fehlen
italien hatte die pandemie in europa am
stärksten getroffen die bilder aus
bergamo gingen im frühjahr 2020 um die
welt mehr als 100 63.000 corona tote
zählt das land bislang die regierung
griff hart durch italien führte als
erstes eu-land eine impfpflicht für
medizinisches personal ein und mit dem
so genannten grünen pass den nachweis
über impfungen genesung oder tests auch
am arbeitsplatz heute nun sind viele
einschränkungen gefallen aus rom annette
hilsenbeck
essen gehen wie früher ohne
beschränkungen wenn s restaurant geht
braucht er platz in italien keinen
greenpeace mehr der belegt dass man
geimpft oder genesen ist und im
innenraum fällt auch die masten pflicht
weniger kontrollen gut für jene die wir
arbeiten ja das war ganz schön viel
arbeit vor allem bis die leute den preis
gefunden hat noch kontrolliert wurde
dafür brauchte man eine person
zusätzlich
italien atmet auf die zahl der
neuinfektionen ist unter kontrolle
über 84 prozent der bevölkerung sind
geimpft und die regierung wagt fast alle
einschränkungen aufzuheben so braucht
man den grünen passt nur noch in
krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen und nur
dort sowie in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln kino oder theater es
masken tragen noch pflicht
wir sind überzeugt dass nach zwei jahren
pandemie regeln und einschränkungen der
zeitpunkt da ist den italienischen
bürgern wieder zuversicht zu vermitteln
wir haben alle voraussetzungen dafür
dass wir einen ganz normalen sommer ohne
einschränkungen erleben werden
auch in geschäften fällt der mundschutz
weg die einen sind darüber erleichtert
die anderen trauen dem ganzen noch nicht
heute morgen habe ich zu meinen
angestellten gesagt entscheidet das mit
der maske einfach selbst sie wollen sie
momentan noch tragen und das ist kein
problem ich trage sie habe nicht mehr so
lang dass wir uns noch im umlauf ist
setze ich die maske auf
ich fühle mich jetzt viel freier in
geschäfte zu gehen ich finds gut
trotzdem vorsicht man gewöhnt sich an
die normalität in italien in vorfreude
auf den sommer
vorfreude auf den sommer jetzt erstmal
vorfreude auf den sport zwei
überraschende medaillen im judo und das
am letzten tag alina bühnen und johannes
frey haben dem deutschen judo-bund einen
erfolgreichen abschluss der
europameisterschaften in sofia in
bulgarien beschert böhm gewinnt gold
frei freut sich über silber
der größte judo erfolg von alina böhm is
perfect rang 17 gegen rang vier der welt
war der em in sofia gegen cuche
systemhaus die niederländerin in blau
die wm-dritte und olympia-siebte böhm
ist die aktivere die die favoritin in
die enge treibt böhm zuletzt zweimal
zweite im grand prix in exzellenter form
ihr erster em titel in der klasse bis 78
kilogramm und bei den männern über 100
kilogramm im zweiten
deutsch-niederländischen duell verliert
johannes freien blaue nach ulm bronze im
team sein erstes em einzel finale golta
newswires am tag der freudentränen von
alina böhm
[Musik]
holger rohn ist der überraschungssieger
beim atp tennisturnier in münchen der 19
jährige däne hatte im turnierverlauf die
beiden deutschen alexander zverev und
oskar otte ausgeschaltet im doppel
gewann das deutsche duo kevin krawietz
andreas mies nach drei sätzen gegen ein
spanisch brasilianisches team für die
zweimalige french open sieger war es der
zweite triumph innerhalb einer woche
und die fußballerinnen des vfl wolfsburg
sind im halbfinale der champions league
ausgeschieden der 2 zu 0 heimsieg gegen
den fc barcelona war nach dem 1 5 im
hinspiel zu wenig für barcelona war es
nach einer serie von 45 pflichtspielen
die erste niederlage vor der
rekordkulisse von mehr als 22.000
zuschauern wo der vfl eine
beeindruckende leistung kurz nach der
pause fasste sich torjägerin tabea was
mit einem herz 1 zu 0 die gäste zwar bis
dahin überlegen wolfsburg aber mit den
toren mitte der zweiten hälfte zwei zu
null nach der 1 2 5 hinspielniederlage
fehlten noch zwei treffer für die
verlängerung aber die chancen wurden
nicht genutzt
barcelona trifft nun im finale in drei
wochen auf lyon wolfsburg hat in der
meisterschaft und im pokal noch
titelchancen
historischer moment gestern in new york
city für diese beiden boxerinnen nämlich
die weltmeisterin kati taylor links und
ihre herausforderinnen am maria serrano
vor fast 20.000 zuschauer sind
zuschauern war es der erste frauen
hauptkampf im madison square garden in
der 140-jährigen geschichte der arena
die ihren siegte nach punkten und
verteidigte erfolgreich ihre vier wm
titel und
das war's vom sport oder auch zeit oder
im wasser zu ergaben noch der blick aufs
wetter so sind die aussichten zum
wochenstart in der mitte und im süden
nach oft freundlichen beginn einzelne
schauer und gewitter sonst wechselnd
bewölkt und meist trocken höchstwerte 13
bis 20 grad und das bleibt erst mal im
großen und ganzen das heute journal um
21.45 mit petri siri wir wünschen ihnen
einen guten start in die neue woche und
sind morgen wieder darauf wieder sehen
[Musik]